that he's left it's more he doesn't want  us to get toxic and hate each other so  it's more like if we separate if he was  to call you right now and be like okay  I'm ready to like can we get back  together yeah I'll say yes so the reason  that you're not together is because of  him then it's not me he's not ready yet  yeah I know I don't think that he can  just leave just because he's got no  money  back no no I think you guys are getting  it wrong again it's not that he doesn't  have money he's not he for him having  600k in your bank isn't enough because  he feels like no no again exactly I  can't tell him enough times I don't care  if you're not making millions no it's  him to believe and accept actually do  you believe what do you say